yeah that thing that apple thing that
you need to get that little wire that
everyone makes but none of them work but
apple yeah it's ridiculous i bought so
many of those things it's i i feel like
what we're talking about i feel like
there's like a uh like a like a there's
like a
committee that works at apple
that makes sure things don't work
properly they go like okay we got this
court to work for two years somebody's
like that's too long i heard they
recently teamed up with the people who
made these mic arms
we'll be right back after pre-roll
big shout out to healy's sleep take
their two-minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you to the mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life take it
from me find your mattress at
helixleep.com
griffin
all right
five
six
seven
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to
another episode of your favorite podcast
what are we talking about
right
[Music]
i'm not gonna do this long because when
rick's here it's always a production so
ladies and gentlemen
with this thing in my mr rick well give
it to me when once you know what i mean
with this thing we have to out of beat
ladies and gentlemen with a singing mic
i'll take it thanks rick glassman
we ain't recording booth the ugly truth
if they were gripping
we need your poopa pissing or whether or
not
connect gonna connect the dots and push
away you give it love again and never
get it stop now how you feeling in the
morning when you drinking juice and
pushing up the booty boop booty boop
grab a titty some [ __ ] some drinking all
the gum then pop it get coffee get copy
cop it up for some now we just living
laughing and living all the turns when
you drip drop kip top dipping on the
girls and the swerving the burpee the
curvy the luscious pla
baby with your titties on my muffin
brushes
edit that flat part out i'm gonna try it
again
[Music]
okay
you invited your your uh your postmates
driver in yeah
rick glassman back on the podcast
welcome rick wow i got such an
adrenaline i haven't performed in so
long
i feel like that when i go to karaoke i
would i want to go up to the mic and be
like it's good to be back everybody
um uh you know just give it up for the
dj such and such give me uh that in g
please go down one octave on that you
know people that take karaoke way too
seriously you go to a karaoke place that
lets you um transpose the song like that
well you could just tell them everything
bring it down every karaoke machine has
like you just go up an octave go down
they all can do it they just don't want
people to know because they'll be
[ __ ] like me that are like okay
let's do it again start over you know
it's kind of like how chipotle doesn't
advertise to do a quesadilla but if you
know you could just ask for one
chipotle does a quesadilla whoops
yeah you know all those places have
secret menus
oh yeah yeah like in and out what's this
internet secret you know well it's not a
secret anymore but it's like you know
animal style and all that kind of oh
all that is supposed to be a secret yeah
taco bell has like uh
they have things too so
i don't know i don't eat that [ __ ]
anymore
i'm just gonna get better my stance i
don't know what i'm doing it's just
really annoying i want to get better
mics over here too because i have a
really good one over there but it's all
expensive and sometimes you just like
i don't know i have a question and
you're going to say uh sometimes you get
cheap and then you're just like you know
what why should these people invest in
you
if you don't invest in yourself this is
like one of those info from our
infomercials
info commercials yeah like i can see you
doing that it's like you know
the commercial would be like make money
make money at podcasting you know learn
how to make money at podcasting but
you're not actually making money you're
podcasting but you're making money
telling people how to podcast yeah you
have a yacht
and there's like it's like betty in a
bikini
you know what i mean i really don't want
to do this right i'm telling you about
it
it's going to be you need people to
think we own this yacht
my dad
another unsatisfied customer
two minutes bro we're almost done we're
just doing a gorilla shoot my dad's been
helping me with when i'm at home with my
ads
and he is such a salesman
he goes uh uh well i don't know
i don't i guess doesn't matter if i push
put this on your thing yeah it doesn't
matter we'll just cut to a clip yeah oh
god is this out is this out tomorrow
it's not tomorrow not enough time you
know i'm doing i'm doing all that stuff
the last time you were on i was like
okay now i got to do all this stuff and
you were like oh my god you had so many
i'll never forget that there was so many
things and snaps and all this stuff and
i was just like i can't do this another
day in the office but listen i've
noticed that i go on other people's way
but is this too much candle because i
could turn it off well it's just
freezing in here so i'm using that for
for warmth
it's turned down still on i know but
it'll turn off and you're gonna be all
sweaty when i go on other people's
podcasts and i bring a little my
creative flair i noticed that the next
episode or two later they kind of
adopted
some of it so i like who
for
everybody like who let's get give me
some specific examples and we'll cut to
those clips uh no i i don't want to do
that oh because there's no clips
that's what i'm saying
are you serious i mean i have i have i
have this i i really put this out there
but i have this
idea
of
i've already compiled like here's me and
then three weeks later here's this
podcast this podcast is doing the same
thing and i want to like let's cut to
rick's podcast right now boom then we're
at your place now no no it's just it's
just the ad that my dad was doing what's
up guys have you taken your helix sleep
quiz yet you got to do it
not being able to sleep because of all
the things that are going on in the
world right now it's totally i totally
get it uh you're stressed yeah your
anxiety sleeping is important and you
may not be getting a great night's sleep
and you think it's because of those
things and that's partly the reason but
what's not helping is your old ass
mattress get off that old mattress it's
time to get a new one people don't even
realize how important it is for your you
know your best sleep and you know how it
affects your body helix sleep has this
two-minute sleep quiz you complete it it
matches your body type and sleep
preference to match the perfect mattress
for you everybody's unique everybody's
got a different body style everybody
sleeps differently i'm a side sleeper i
took the quiz
it matched me with a perfect mattress
now i sleep way better i totally feel
the difference so make sure
you check that out you know if you sleep
on your side your back your stomach
maybe you move around you toss and turn
all night um
and this is like you know this is we
don't it's so funny how we don't even
think about
how the mattress affects this so if
you're looking for a mattress take the
quiz you order the mattress and it
matches to you and it'll just drop it
off at your
door
shipping is free helix is awesome and
don't even take my word for it they they
were awarded the number one best overall
mattress in 2020 by gq and wired
magazine go to helixsleep.com griffin
take their two minutes leave quiz and
they'll match you to the customized
mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
listeners at helixsleep.com
griffin is there anything interfering
with your happiness
you're stressed you got anxiety you got
some personal issues i'm recommending
therapy man therapy helped me i worked
on boundary issues with therapy
you know hair therapy you know it
doesn't solve your problems you know
they're not gonna it's not a magic pill
therapy helps you organize your thoughts
therapy helps you recognize and pinpoint
the causes of your feelings with a
professional who recognizes these
patterns you know a therapist will say
oh you know what this is because of this
this and this and it'll help you think
about it and you'll be able to maybe
overcome those things because you now
have a better understanding of what's
going on with you all right and better
help is all about that you'll get timely
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly or video or phone
sessions all without having to sit in
front of some uncomfortable waiting room
you know i can't stand that you know
when you're in the waiting room and you
feel crazy you know they take that out
of it it's very comfortable the services
is available for their clients worldwide
you know they're they're experts in
depression stress anxiety family
conflicts lgbt matters if that's your
thing self-esteem trauma sleeping
anything you share is confidential it's
convenient it's professional and most
importantly it's affordable
i want you to start living a happier
life today as a listener you'll get 20
10
10 off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at betterhelp.com
griffin
join over 1 million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com griffin for 10
off your first month
let's start living happier healthier
more productive life let's get back to
the show
but i thought i want to like i want to
put this compilation together but i
can't put it out there so it gets leaked
like somebody else posts it oh hilarious
and it's just like you know people
ripping off rick glassman's podcast and
you're just like but if you go back far
enough you can see it's from like the
reddit rick glassman but instead of an
eye it's a one like i forgot i don't
know how to hide
i didn't post that it's glass man you
know
yeah but no everyone needs to find their
thing and you know sometimes there's
parallel thought and sometimes it's just
ripping off and uh
not like it's not like i'm saying nobody
was selling mattresses until me i'm just
saying the animation and this and these
but you know what they say
what do they say flattery is uh what is
it is uh sometimes it's not good enough
yes steven is the best way to like you
know sometimes you're not doing good
enough and you can steal from other
people i don't know is that can people
actually i mean i wonder if there is a
thing where people are
um mad at other people actually i've
actually heard this i was i was talking
to a female podcast host can i get a
blanket
you're so stupid
that was you talking to the female
podcast host
oh a closet blanket
you selling these no this is a rap gift
i should
thanks
so rick has a blanket
um yeah it's a nice box
so they were uh she told i'm not gonna
say who but she was telling me that she
did some segment on her podcast and then
another female podcast host hit her up
like you know you're stealing my essence
like that's what i do on my thing and i
just go dang like there are so many
podcasts like how can you think you're
original
sure same with stand up like there's so
many different ways
but also sometimes
you know
sometimes i know what you're saying like
you know it when you see it you know you
know when you see you know what if i
explain it to you and you know it if it
happens right after you you know it's
just no no no but you're watching
somebody's pockets and they're going
like this all right guys we're going to
cut to this and they do this instead of
this
and they go
yeah and then they do you try to
confront them they're like rick i'm this
is the clap we changed our podcast to
the wash your hands podcast it's not the
same well no you're right and that's why
i'm not talking about it
but we all know
when i start getting comments on my page
uh where oh you're copying and they're
naming other podcasts that i've seen
them adopt my thing i'm like that's when
i get like well oh no no oh well the
frustrating part about that no that just
lets you know
how not popular your podcast is compared
to these other podcasts
because it would be like if if it would
be like you look on rogan
and just for some reason roger decided
to do a snap you're done
well
the truth is i have um whether
i have at least for my own like i'm good
is uh is
it's time stamped you've seen me been
doing this even if you've never seen me
been doing this people don't care but
but it would be this it would be if you
put out a special
right that nobody saw
that's rude and then
a couple years later rogan does this and
does a bit you know what that was the
highest rated sp special when that came
out that year in on showtime
i was just joking i've seen it i love it
it's hysterical
see how you see what he does to me but
go on uh
and then rogan does that that your bit
and then people see that clip and
they're like in like they're like oh
eric stole it but anyone could be like
look at the date i know but they still
do that it doesn't even matter but that
doesn't bother me you know what i don't
know i know what you're saying but but
nobody that bothers me it was going to
say it has to bother you because like
okay because i have a real world example
i used to like but
before i was going to do my last special
american warrior i was going to um
i had like you're gonna take those off
for a minute they hurt my ears just take
them off you don't need them just keep
just keep talking to the mic like how
you're doing like this you know i'm just
gonna keep this so i can keep track of
the uh sound because i don't have my guy
here today um
so i was doing this joke and it was
about you know i made the reference
bananagate
in my the joke i made the reference and
i was doing it for a while preparing
and then chappelle came out with a thing
one of his specials came out and he said
the same phrasing you know and then the
next day like adam eager at the comedy
store was like yo man did you see this
thing because he knew i'd been doing
this right right and i was like i saw it
and i was like damn
there goes that yeah you know what i
mean yeah it's um
there's a there's a
there's a real like you don't have to
use them i prefer it especially because
in this the way this is set up a lot of
you're talking like you're not looking
at me
so but when i get here in my ears it's
it's not as distracting
oh my god does that make sense yeah i'm
not really i'm i'm yeah i know but like
watch this
i get you yeah
what i need to do
eventually i'm gonna get another camera
we'll figure it out but for now we're
doing like this
when you
i almost want to like i really want to i
see i can't move the room around i'll
figure it out
boy what do you want to do i don't know
because i'm thinking like if i put it in
this corner instead so i have a chair
coming this way and a chair going that
way so then we're like already like sort
of facing each other then the camera i
don't know yeah but then yeah so that
would be 180 it would basically be our
side profiles like this yeah but i would
still have a camera coming straight on
you know and then another camera figure
you come on my podcast all of a sudden
you want more cameras
i know i was the first person to do
desi arnaz all of a sudden
good and good for me for knowing what
we're talking about
do you know andy kozell yeah uh you
don't
but he's he's uh
we refer to him at least we used to was
a like the best couch comic have you
ever heard that term i hadn't until him
no what is that he's the funniest guy in
the room when you're in a room is he
like i've never experienced that i think
he's hysterical but but it's saying like
not that he's not good at stand-up i
think he's funny on stage but he's the
type of guy that's like you know when
people say oh i could do stand-up i make
all my friends laugh yeah he's the guy
that makes all his friends he's the guy
that does that in a room full of
comedians oh yeah like he's on the couch
and he's just kills gotcha and uh
uh
wait what were we just talking about is
it a room full of comedians in there
before that what did you say i don't
know
forgot now we were talking about
something this is what happens we have
to like this is why we should you know
what we desi ernest yes you know what we
need when we do our podcast is a court
reporter yeah i know i thought about it
no [ __ ] i said it first time stamping
sometimes sometimes i will be like uh i
think i've done this with you sometimes
i'll be like no we'll watch it back but
we don't really get to watch it so what
i do is i then show the audience what it
was and then when we come back i have us
do two takes oh you were right or see i
told you
just in case yeah yeah yeah
so oh man that just that's just so much
i i you're i i want to you know you
should film just one time you should
film the guy that edits for you you
should film him watching him looking at
your all your notes yeah and just him
just being like [ __ ] i've done a uh i've
done for my patreon i've done that kind
of stuff uh with my animator and just
all the notes and how many veins we
could have because it's on the dick
because it's too early and like you know
pooping's funny but i didn't ask this
person and they open their mouth but
maybe if we just make it piss it's less
you know he's like yeah that makes sense
that makes sense
uh but uh andy
said uh it's about me that desi arnaz
couch comic i don't remember my point of
reference
is
nothing before 1995.
so like if he says anything he's like
man he just gets so upset because his
his references are so deep
that like it's hysterical if you get it
right but like you know i don't get it
but he thinks it's like yeah it's like
an ewok pushy pop when this chair is not
even made of leather and i'm like andy
nobody understands that but he's like no
you that was just 1994. like okay okay
you have to at some point you got to
take responsibility and just kind of
dumb it down a little bit
oh my god dude do you even do you even
have enough do you have any time to like
like i never hear about you like liking
things like television shows and stuff
like that do you even watch you know you
don't hear about like i'm saying you
never talk about those kinds of things
like that like you wrote do you do
do you watch tv shows yeah beginning to
end like yeah you know oh i mean when
i'm not working on the podcast that's
all i do oh really yeah all i do like
what what are you watching right now i'm
watching uh only murders in the building
uh the new uh apple show with
uh watch apple shows is it apple or is
it hula i think it's apple yeah it's
with uh martin short and steve martin oh
i heard about this supposed to be really
i saw them on um
what real talk with bill maher
you know what when bill maher hits
do you like do you watch bill maher show
yeah yeah i watch it every week i love
you you'd be good on it i love how he
talks about things i think that it's
hard i don't care if you're a liberal
like if you are a
self-proclaimed liberal you say i am
liberal once you get over 50 or get
around that time
it's hard to like you know
be like okay
uh not have some
middle conservative leanings just
because like you're making your own
money and especially somebody that's
wealthy also because because each
generation i don't know much so at least
the past three
the the new generation of liberal is way
further away from what
we grew up with oh you know what that's
okay
right you're right you know what that's
a great point rick i think you could see
that too because you know when when
these people talk about some people talk
about ronald reagan that that error and
you and it's like way less conservative
than like say george bush and you know
but even though people yeah but then you
get to get into the reaganomics of it
all right and then it's not but there
are some things that are similar you
know because they're still conservative
but i'm just saying like he was way more
when you look back on it you're like
well this is probably more left-leaning
than of
on that side yeah everyone's trying to
get away from their parents generation
yeah yeah yeah and if you're
left you just go more left and if you're
right you just
kind of stay there i think it can be
either way that's what i'm saying sure
yeah but anyway getting back to it i lo
i love that i love why and they were on
that show he uh i don't remember what we
were talking about who's that steve
martin uh martin
i watched uh a seven and a half minute
monologue not mine like it was a closing
rant but monologue you know that he did
it was on cancel culture but it was all
on the stage of matt damon did you see
that
no cause matt damon's got in trouble
again recently for admitting that he
stopped using the f word oh yeah i
remember that yeah and he just goes on
for seven minutes and it's all it's you
know and you could you could you could
put in any cancel culture thing into
this but it's all
really matt damon
you know that he does this with clean
water and feeling matt damon he's just
like man
he loves matt i mean i love matt damon i
don't know if it's about him loving matt
damon so much it's it's about um it's
just yes but also if you watch it you
think he really loves matt damon who
doesn't
but also it was like it's [ __ ] matt
damon
you know i caught a clip of chris's
chris deleo's podcast and he was talking
about matt damon too and how he was
talking about it but i could tell it was
like personal to him too like just about
you know everything that he's dealt with
but i think you know he was saying well
you know it was just freezing in here
it's freezing so you're gonna you're
gonna melt the mic
i don't know i'm gonna defrost it
it's off it's not even on
it's not it's on it's not
it might be on
yeah it's a hundred percent off that's
gonna turn off it's gonna turn off
i could see it's on
otherwise rick just you'll be fine it
keeps you sharp you're i like you right
now you're sharp you're in the moment
okay just adding so many mustaches onto
me i'm telling you it's my thing
you know what i love but let me
you talking chris and matt damon we'll
get back to it is i now have developed
this team uh with that work with me on
my podcast to where uh it makes my job a
lot easier because i would be you know
we need to do that but now they get what
i want yeah also they do their own thing
everyone's great thank you so much but
also it now gets to the point where the
shorthand is uh when it's usually you
but when somebody does this we just know
just put in
tom my animator sorry tom you know the
drill it's just it's just and he just
then and if there's yeah anyway
something's flying on the person's face
well that this is usually just mustache
stuff i just kind of got into this
i i i uh what a weird shorthand you know
what's been
that's been happening now that i've been
leaving the house since my podcast came
out is i'm getting recognized like
and i've never been recognized before
and even when you're on a nbc show no
one recognizes correct the the amount
that i'm recognized from the podcast
which isn't even you know is
doesn't touch
what undateable was
and
with my mask on and there was a guy who
who uh
i saw yesterday goes
he was so sweet and he's like yeah but
in his defense your math say rick
glassman t-i-s-o
yeah how would they know it's me i'm
also wearing the six-lead merchandise
uh it's just a white man for some reason
you're carrying a rug for some reason
you never know when an opportunity
strikes by the way put in the commercial
so uh uh and he says uh you know i i i
don't know if you got my my message but
i dm'd you i thought it would be cool if
you started selling mustaches for merch
i'm like i get why you're saying that i
don't know where i would go and also i
don't want to be the mustache guy it's
just you know you do something and then
it happens like my mom calls herself a
queen because she's a black woman you
know
your jewish mom is a black woman now she
has
and i mean this you know she watch
empire is that like you know what i mean
because that's usually how it started
let me tell you which cookie
she sells perfume and she just talks
about everyone's smells and she's
putting lotion on them she's just big
into lotion yeah uh she has black woman
energy
and
and uh so cultural appropriation but go
on
they took it from my mom
okay but but there are more black women
than there are of my mom so nobody knows
that but time stamping
my mom was doing it first my mom was
doing lotion way before look at nobody
was putting covers over their couches
before my mom
sounds stupid um
you met a fan mustaches go my mom so now
my mom everyone gets my mom stuff that
says queen
because my mom liked queen stuff so now
everything in the house is gifts of
queen queen like you know somebody oh
your fans are sending your mom no i'm
saying when when when somebody knows of
a surface level character trait of
another person oh you know eric loves
snakes
so every birthday i don't know what
let's not put that out there eric loves
to be miserable
you know but like whatever the thing
would be
i don't know do you have a thing i used
to have i used to be uh like teenage
mutant ninja turtles and skulls i used
to love skulls so people would always
get me skull keychains and stuff oh
right right after what sometimes you
just go damn i wish i would have said
something else
like bitcoin yes yeah yeah yeah because
then you become this thing the cash guy
yeah
you know when i went on uh when i went
to caroline's with you caroline's yeah
caroline's
i
yet to had discover the double-sided
mustache sticky tape that shout out to
taran killam from snl he knows all about
mustaches because you were wasting your
mustache and they're five bucks a pop i
get good mustaches yeah and you were
like i throw this away i was like why
why don't you just reuse them you didn't
say that yes i did well not to me yes i
did well i'm still terrible
but i know but i used to yeah just my
mustache budget was through the [ __ ]
roof
i swear to 40 a weekend on mustaches
all right chris matt damon mustache
remember now oh yeah i remember uh but
he was just making a point about you
know so here's matt damon
you know he's he he's like trying to
grow
you know so he's he's grown he's saying
i'm not doing this and he's still
getting canceled you know what i mean
it's like so what do you want him to do
yeah matt dame the way that uh bill
marge said it was where you know he was
late to the party we could say welcome
come on in yeah or we could say i got
here before you die it was just like
so funny yeah like just say he's here
yeah so he suffers from that issue of
not being born perfect and not realizing
that he could change
or realizing he can't that's like that
was the monologue yeah
i guess
everybody was talking about like that
but that's what i when i saw it but i
thought it was also personal to chris
just because he was like hey look you
change you you know you try to grow and
people don't let you yeah you know what
i mean that's why you just gotta just do
it on your own dude if you want a
blanket ask for it yeah and you get it
um i don't know it's just
it's just it's just weird like i'm not i
don't necessarily care about like i used
to be like really
you know because of my age you know you
want these people that's like you know
sensitivity everybody says you know and
all this kind of stuff and uh and i
realize it's like you know what we're
talking about it's like generations
change and they like you know they do
what they do you know what i mean
yeah i
have been getting sensitive on podcasts
not that i do it much but uh
intentionally just talking about this
subject matter i just i'm always
whenever i do i don't know what i i
totally get what you're saying but i'll
just end it like this because i agree
with you completely and that's what ends
up happening people go oh they're
talking about and that's because my
point about it is i feel that way when i
listen simple point i'm trying to make
is that we're all sensitive and i think
that like so i don't mind when people
are sensitive i just think it's just how
they weaponize it but for me it's like
because like i think comedians in
general are super sensitive hyper
sensitive yeah i think we're
hypersensitive people yeah
you know what i mean and so uh you know
so there's the uh so there's the thing
with that all right button on that so
we're done with that so you said oh so
you say you're watching what's the show
you oh you watch that show and i'm also
watching um
nine perfect strangers on hulu nicole
kidman and uh bobby cannavale and
melissa mccarthy oh i wanted to i saw
you know i love melissa mccarthy like
anything she's in i'm gonna watch it i
think she really like i just find her
it's like her and jet li movies
i could see that you know that yeah so
if i like i don't know what it was i
loved jet li both of the tits
now right so they uh
so then why does jet lift hits now or
does melissa mccarthy not have tits now
i have no idea i don't know what point
either one of us are making at this
point i know what point i'm making
but i just like you have your thing like
there's like i don't know what your
thing is but for me like i have a thing
like so for a long time like i would you
know when dvds were a thing i would just
be like whatever jetley movie comes out
i'm getting that dvd and i'm just gonna
like you know romeo must die and all
these movies i love all that [ __ ] but mr
mccarthy same thing anything she's in
i'm like let me check this out even if i
don't like it i always think she's great
in anything i i agree
one of those people for me is if bobby
cannavale is in it
who's who's that uh he's
uh he's married to rose byrne which i
think is a cool connection because rose
byrne and melissa mccarthy are always in
comedies together you know if you saw
him yeah that's one of my looks i fell
in love with him in the paul giovanni
indy
wrestling teacher lawyer comedy
drama
win win do you remember that movie did
you ever see it
did you find him yet
oh oh this guy yeah yeah yeah he's put
it up so you don't have to
edit it in um he's so
did the might did the audio go out or is
that just my headphones did your audio
go yeah i don't hear it anymore
what did you do
what did you do what did
hello yeah it's working now
uh he's so good he's so funny and
charismatic and he's a good actor yeah
but he's he always plays like he's he's
good at he's good at playing like a like
a like a bad guy
you know he's always a bad guy i get
that he's played some bad guys but i've
discovered him where he's always like uh
a little bit of a buffoon not a bad guy
or like or he's like the boyfriend
that's getting cheated on or he's like
this like you know lovable something
that you're just like come on man you
can do better so lovable yeah yeah yeah
here's a he's your guy you like all his
movies he's not if i had to pick one i
don't think it's him but he's when i see
bobby kind of valleys and like i want to
see that okay
win-win i'm telling you guys because a
lot of people i've recommend that movie
a lot don't know about it women it's so
good
i'll check it out paul uh paul giomany
plays this uh
wrestling coach in a high school he's
also a lawyer
and he's not they're not doing well
financially and
this kid
i don't want to give too much of the
story but like this basically this kid
comes in and he's this amazing wrestler
and bobby cannavale is just his
his rich friend that wants to teach in
coach wrestling too so he's just it
would be like if you got the if you were
a wrestling fan and got the opportunity
to go in the wwe it's like what ron
funches is doing yeah yeah yeah yeah
have you seen what ron is doing yeah
yeah he's like actually yeah being
thrown in rings and stuff it's nuts and
he's just like this enthusiastic stupid
funny anyway that's good stuff
i don't know i i just like
i i don't know if i like the binge
watching part of it and then i i find
myself not being able to stop like i
started this series on uh
what is it on showtime with brian
cranston called your honor
and then i i it's already been out and i
i started watching it and then i
couldn't stop
that's why i watched it don't like that
10 episodes no i don't like it because i
actually like
i want to live in the story for a little
while so you want a week week i need i
like week to week even that feeling of
anticipation of being upset that i can't
watch it is the same energy and you're
just like oh and you wait for then but
then you kind of get to how to me i feel
like it's hard to get to know the
characters or really delve into the
story when it's already done i mean game
of thrones those kinds of shows i mean
if game of thrones was a binge watchable
in a way like that i don't think it
would have been as big i think you
needed that time you needed these yeah
you could get that time season to season
you know like it's still eight years i
don't i still don't think that uh i
don't i don't i disagree with you i
don't think so at all i don't think it's
the same thing i don't think any binge
watch show like that like it gets big
and then it just
tapers off well for game of thrones i
didn't start watching until season four
and i love
binge watching the first three and a
half seasons i understand because it's
already going because the point that
energy was i need to catch up i love
this show and now you want to see where
it goes
i don't know i think there's a lot of
shows i started watching on netflix and
i just i just kind of have an idea of
the show
i can like when you watch a show like
game of thrones and you're watching it
every week you kind of get to know all
the characters you kind of like also the
way they tell the story they give an
episode to an ancillary character no but
still even still though i think it has
to do with like it being spread out like
that because there's a show like
umbrella academy and i think umbrella
academy is great i auditioned for that
oh you did yeah that's good i could see
you on that that was one of the uh i was
really proud of myself in that audition
because i i i
i had a good audit like when i was work
practicing i'm like like this is
something i could get like i was i
brought something to it oh that's good
and i went in and i auditioned and i
just it was fine it was fine you know it
wasn't bad it was fine and i walked out
and that was the end of it and like [ __ ]
and i i'm like and i i went back in i go
listen i don't know like five minutes
later you know and i was the last one so
they're you know shit's closed and i
went in and
this is you know i don't know you recall
i could do better and i want to and
they're like do it
and then i went and i crushed it and i
walked out i'm like good for me yeah and
then well then because that because you
really wanted the story to end with and
that's how i got on umbrella academy and
i've been well they wouldn't pay me
enough i turned it down
that's better i like that keep that keep
that make that reality that's fun about
auditioning when because now it's all
zoom or you know or on tape i hate it
but that in between stuff when you get
to walk in in a different energy than
the character you're going to bring so
you could really like you feel you feel
them oh he can act yeah because when you
do a self tape they just think okay this
is the person right you know but i i
don't but the only thing is
i feel like self tapes um
there's pros and cons i mean the pro is
you get to do it as many times as you
want to you get it right but you could
do that in the casting office anyway
yeah but i think that like
not as many times as you you can like
because you can really tweak it and how
you tweak it that stuff you're doing to
tweak it when you're like like if you
and i are working on an audition that's
stuff we're doing to be like all right
rick why don't you do it again maybe try
it this way all that stuff that's what
you do before you go into the audition
no i understand that but what i'm saying
is having all that on the self tape is
the pro for self tape okay that's a pro
for that okay
uh
and then you know the pro for like going
in going in is you know you're getting
this like you know you're interacting
with them and you're doing you know
doing all the stuff but there's a lot of
factors that go into that too because a
lot of factors of like is this before
lunch for them after lunch yeah like
where are we in the audition process you
know because that's important too how
many people have they seen to know what
they don't want or they could tell you a
little cheats like don't do this yeah
yeah or sometimes i've gone in on
auditions when they've already picked
the person that they want and they're
just still seeing and i'm like usually
i'm like what am i doing here then yeah
you know the shitty part of it yeah i'm
not gonna change your mind or it's like
or it's like what i realized even now
more than ever at the level that i don't
know i'm not some high level i'm just
saying like i get we're going in for the
roles where big people are also going
out yeah they're no no they're not going
in see i'm going for the roles and
they're offering it to these people you
know sure so like it's like like i was
going after this one part right now they
go well you know they're sending out a
big offer for someone so i go well when
little rail rejects it can you
yeah you told me about that you know
what i mean can you uh can you like get
me in you know you know but it's like so
i know now where it's like they're just
so our job is to change their mind so
it's like it's like where do you want to
do that do you want to change their mind
by sending a great tape that you've sort
of edited you know you have the the best
takes uh or is it like you want to
change their mind by going you know you
want to be in front of them and being
like yo what's up how are you doing you
also want them to get to know you and
like you for the next thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so i don't know what you
wanna i i sometimes sometimes i prefer
to go in
when i feel like i really have a chance
and i always know when that's the case
it's like
they give you the stuff on monday eric
you take the the audition's thursday
then i know
they haven't seen a bunch of people but
a lot of times it's like
uh this is tomorrow
you know see i don't take that as they
already have with one i take that as and
they've seen a lot of people you weren't
their first choice uh and now they're
like we haven't figured it out let's
kind of broaden our reach to find other
people i know but what i'm saying is if
you're giving somebody six pages and
you're like the auditions tonight how
good you could be at it right the
auditions tomorrow then i just feel like
oh they don't really this isn't this
this isn't this doesn't feel important
to me right like this doesn't feel
important to them this phase in the
auditions i don't think people that's
how i look i appreciate this isn't a
poor actress because
you know
if you get the job you get paid well
yeah where a lot of people in this
business they don't
but i still don't think they appreciate
how hard it is to like
hey you're not paying us to audition
yeah but i have to shoot this scene yeah
and
work on it and pay somebody to help me
yeah coach me um
uh my friend shout out to john and
alison they're writers it's the same
thing they talk about how how many
things they have to write for free to
maybe get a job on something but like
they put
their
we have to learn that we have to do a
scene and one of once when it's three or
four scenes and 12 pages
and like you ever go like i just don't
want to do this oh dude all the time
i feel that way when it's like i said
what i'm saying is like when i say like
it's the next day just keep it over
there for yourself when it's like the
next day i'm like oh they don't what is
this i mean come like i always feel like
even commercials
this is a big thing on commercials too
that i feel like it's like what are you
doing they spend all this time prepping
getting everything ready they know where
they're gonna shoot they know they've
had the crew and everything you're
saying when you go in for when you yeah
no i'm saying yeah they already have all
the stuff ready for the commercial to go
and then they take two days to book the
talent which to me seems to be the most
important part of the commercial and i
just go wow it
seems i think it's crazy it seems ass
backwards i think it's easy to book i
mean don't disrespect to the commercial
game and not everything's the same but
why even audition i mean don't even get
me started it's to make people feel
important i guess just you
98 of it is what you look like that's 98
for commercial because if you can't do
this
whoa
great
like that's the amount of lines for
commercial i i don't agree with that i
don't agree with that i mean i think
there there is some especially like when
you see like a really funny commercial
and there's like some great timing
that's what i'm saying for a really
funny thing where you got to see
comedians and you improvise or whatever
sure most the commercials i've done a
fair amount of commercials some of them
were funny bigger lie most of them are
just
i booked i booked a commercial that
because they liked my head shot they
thought it was funny
and i i didn't get the one i auditioned
for but they put me in for another thing
because they're all interchangeable yeah
yeah yeah yeah would you like another
taste of this sucker or whatever the
[ __ ] yeah they're just
anyway i know what you're saying i mean
sometimes sometimes you get booked
like if they're gonna this is what
because this is what you're trying to
say
in my opinion is like if you're just
gonna book me off my head shot then just
do that anyway or if you're just gonna
book me off of one line or usually a
facial expression yeah you ever go into
these ones where they have so many
people so they see three people at a
time yeah and like you'll be on the you
three are on the bus and you're standing
and then then once the bus moves be like
oh so let me see you guys do that and
then three was like oh okay thank you
i just did like i just did a commercial
you know and i just i think my full
audition is for ibm but for football
season i don't know what i don't even i
don't know what ibm even sells anymore
so i don't even know what i i i couldn't
tell from the shoot like what is this
about like i couldn't get a read on what
it actually was
yeah and the way they were filming it
too they had this robot camera man it
was crazy
like this robot was like and the camera
was like a long cylinder and it was just
you know right here you know and they
just go position one then it was like
they set it up position two and then we
did 17 takes like this
you know mustache mustache mustache god
damn it
i'm gonna send this to your editor you
ever uh you ever do commercials that
don't come out i've done a few i've done
a commercial where i got cut out of it
and it was really annoying it was a
super bowl spot you know you have to
super that's the sucky thing because
you're at the super bowl party and it's
like you know and you know it's about to
be yeah it's like here it is
here it is y'all then it's like okay i'm
coming
this guy wasn't in this part it's coming
and then it's like that's it and i was
like what
why was i cut out of that there's
nothing bigger in the commercial game
than you know it's a super bowl spot
yeah i know i but actually but if you
really know you know that because they
only play during the super bowl and you
don't get the resistance it depends on
who's who's in the commercial like if
it's some huge actor in the commercial
that's a kiss of death because they're
not paying that guy
they pay that guy the one time so they
have a
we could play this many times and then
that's it you want to be in one of those
ones where i did a campaign for intel
with jim parsons
where it it yeah the most i made yeah
but he was the intel guy at that point
right you know he was like in all those
commercials right that's still he's
being paid for the spokesperson not just
the one spot yeah but sometimes if it's
like someone would like it's t-pain or
like you know what i mean what would be
a better he's good on social media now
yeah he's really funny i played video
games with him and uh on air griffin
gaming you should get him on this yeah i
know well i don't know him like that
well that's why it'll be a great
interview yeah you're right you're right
um t-pain
you got to come on here
we want to hear stories if i'm on a boat
we want to hear stories about how you're
such a great singer that's a great
example of when people think that's
somebody's thing yeah
he talks about it yeah yeah that's he's
great when he talks about it because
he's you can see the bitterness yeah i
can sing damn it i just found a little
trick yeah so it's like it would be like
with me doing it and he's going to and a
little trick everybody's doing
[Laughter]
now he didn't he'll say he didn't invent
oh yeah because that was roger but he
put it in that and it's like
we know you know what i mean yep
computer that was like that was way back
every people were doing that for but he
used to have to put something in his
mouth it was like weird how technology
has changed
tell me about it
i don't know anything before 95 dude
uh
but yeah man i i i want to get i like
that i'm going out for a bunch of
commercials now and i would love to just
like start booking those things
you know those are fun do you go out for
uh double scale do you insist
i think my people they do whatever they
can you know because i know because i i
remember booking commercials getting on
set scale is getting paid just the base
amount you can get paid yeah well that
yeah yeah but that's that's my reunion
loss but i remember booking this one
commercial i got all set and then ad
people are there and whatever you know
and the guy's looking at me and he's
like man when i saw your headshot i was
like we gotta book him you know because
he's a workaholics fan and you're like
[ __ ] i know that was like i wasn't even
you know i feel like i wasn't even so it
wasn't even like this great audition
that i did it was like it was like you
know so that made me feel like so you
wasted everybody's time like everybody's
time was wasted because the guy said to
me he said i took your head shot and i
put it off to the side i was like
this is it and then it was like they had
to just do all this dog and pony show
[ __ ] and then there's like you know
there's also like infighting going on
sometimes too so you have the ad people
yeah you have the director then you know
the casting you know and i and i've
heard this where it's like
the director might be like the director
might be like i love this guy this guy i
want right here you know but then ad
people are like well you know we don't
want that guy you know but they're
having this kind of thing so i remember
like a casting person telling me
she was like eric i know you've worked
with this director before but please
don't go in there and act like you know
each other
you know and i was like i didn't get it
but now i i got it later you know cause
because i remember like because another
time i walked into the room and i saw
the guy i was like oh what's up man
and then like the ad people were just
kind of like
commercial auditioning's fun though it
is
but you know you have to have a thing
where it's like you have to know that
this is dumb and silly
and don't let that be in your head
because the one time it got in my head i
was like i realized how idiotic this was
it was a target commercial and you had
to like change the words of like a
really popular song like say like like
say if it was like van halen it was jump
you had to change inhaling
you had to change it to like you know
like it was like pencils go ahead and
pencil or whatever you know and it was
just like as i was doing it i was like
oh no this is really stupid oh as in
like pride like i'm here in this yes
yeah yeah i realized i was like oh this
is really dumb and i just i i didn't
have the energy for you i heard eric
made in hollywood i wonder what he's
doing right now just pencil
yeah
so it was like but normally normally i i
go into these things and i go what's the
joke like that's my tip for anybody
that's like wants to be a commercial
actor or if you go
you know just look at that page
get the joke and then just play on that
because then they'll love that you know
i remember booking this really big
commercial
because i got the joke and i changed it
and it got and i thought everybody loved
it you know and i bought the part you
know and i knew it i felt it i was like
oh i'm booking that
you know so it's just like so but once
you go but if you think the joke is dumb
you can't have that energy i learned
that on undateable
uh i remember that where i was so
judgmental about the joke because
because specifically like you didn't
even have a handle on this
thing
at the time so that must have really
been hard for you uh it was when i'm
watching my best friends on the show
thriving yeah and i'm at you know
looking back that was
you know take the [ __ ]
job and enjoy it right yeah yeah and i
figured it out before the show ended but
even more so i'm doing this this uh this
tv show this dramedy about autism and
it's the first time i've done something
that's not a straight comedy
and there was during it there were some
choices that obviously i'm i can't make
but in rehearsal when we're being light
and just having fun i'm making these big
choices and it's they're funny you know
it's not the tone though yeah and
and that's when i realized this is how
you do a multicam
what i'm getting at is like
finding the joke
that you obviously shouldn't do just
like i thought i shouldn't do this on a
dateable i was judging this joke it's
the same thing here i'm making fun of
something
does that make sense oh it makes perfect
sense so instead of being like this joke
isn't good
versus having the mentality of this
character thinks this joke is good
that's acting and that yeah but that's
you know like don't judge the comedy
live in the character yeah yeah and it's
for real just be you know what and
that's about finding out like having a
and this is the hardest thing is having
an understanding of why whatever you're
doing what are you servicing yeah that's
where that's the hardest thing got in
the way and i still get that still bugs
me sometimes too it really does like
because you want to be the scorer maybe
and you're there it's not necessarily
man it's not necessarily that at all
like this pilot that i did that didn't
get picked up the bastards um but i
remember in the shooting of the the
pilot you know and you know it's like
there's moments
where it's like you know as a comic you
you think you have to be big but it's
like a multi-cam you know i remember the
director saying to me a couple times she
said eric don't do this like a multi-cam
do this like a single cam you know and
it was like
it was it was her saying to me you don't
need to be big you know you're already
you're big
you know what i'm saying yeah like don't
act just you know play because because
even when i'm like you know i'm gonna be
the funniest thing in this situation you
know
how people react to me and how i'm
reacting to them just you know and so
sometimes you know you have these
moments you do something and so i've
been doing that you put a great sentence
to is just live in the moment of this
character and so that's what i was doing
and then like you know you would get a
you'd get a laugh or a thing
uh that you go oh man i didn't
i didn't i really wish i had a better
handle on knowing if i do it like this
people are going to love it i don't know
so i just have to like i do it that's
that's where it when you're doing it in
front of a live studio audience it gets
it's that
it changes though yeah oh well every
time yeah so you don't know when to hold
when i mean it's not that you get used
to it but it's just an interesting
technique what i mean of like you're not
expecting
yeah to laugh there so you know you have
to kind of like but see as a comic
i like okay so i did um one day at a
time i was in the pilot of one day at a
time the new one you know well it was an
old one yeah before 95. oh yeah that was
the biggest one of the biggest sitcoms
ever dude anyway uh norman lear you know
same guy anyways
i know so we're so they're very
meticulous on the multicam you know like
when you're
all the rehearsing and the blocking it's
like very meticulous you know and this
director she's like one of these
renowned you know and she's very
meticulous brick if this is on the set
she might come over here and go like
this
okay let's do it again you know and i'm
like okay
and then she's one of these people too
that she's like just hold the script
hold the script because i want these
words and she's basically saying you're
not off book we're not
not only that you're gonna be off book
so hold on to this because i want you to
get these words exactly right yeah you
know so i'm like got it you know what i
mean yeah okay and so but as a comic i'm
when we're doing the thing i'm like
they're gonna laugh here like you know
what i mean and we're not giving it the
pause that it needs like i knew so when
it was live taping
it was like pat i said something that it
was like
you know what i mean and everybody was
kind of like oh [ __ ] you know like it's
like
because it was so many note sessions it
was a note session for sony a note
session for netflix a note session for
the creator and you know they're they're
giving all their no doing all their
things
you know and it's just like you just go
if you can survive all that nonsense and
still find some funny
you know my session my session there's
there's some times where something could
and or should get a laugh and doesn't
and it's it's it's like because the
stars weren't aligned and what i mean by
that is like it could be anything but a
big one is is uh a lot of times people
in the audience they're watching the
screen right because the the people on
stage are a little too far away you go
back and forth and they're so they're
watching the live game
now in editing they they could just like
a podcast you could tighten that fits
makes the switches right but if like if
my joke is is uh something that follows
a facial expression of yours or
something like yeah it's funny but they
the camera switch missed something so it
it doesn't cut back to you so it's not
you know yeah or something whatever the
editing is the funny you know what i
mean that's the thing too that's what i
you know i mean yeah no no for sure rick
that's what makes what you do good great
you know it's like that's what i'm
saying so you have to tell you have to
tell people you have to show them yeah
it's like just like re reaction is what
makes things funny and it's like that's
the reason why like if you guys watching
if you if you're a office fan
if you love the office and you think the
office is so funny you need to ask
yourself why do you think the office is
so funny
i would say uh
many of the funniest moments in the
office
is just jim
looking at the camera
like something ridiculous happens and
then he looks at the camera and we're
laughing and then and then you laugh why
are you laughing i mean i have an answer
right now i have an answer for you
uh
we know and like the characters that's
it if you we don't know and like the
characters it's just you have to work so
one hundred percent
with you
i disagree with you i disagree with you
completely because that's that's jim you
know that's michael no
that's what it turns into but yes that's
not it rick at all
because like when you go to a play that
you've never seen for the first time and
it's a comedy play you don't need to
know these no but you don't your
performances and the things that happen
i don't mean you know jim and that he
has a thing for pam and later on i mean
we see
when jim looks to camera
we know that guy we know he's self-aware
he's thinking what i'm thinking okay but
that's what it is well okay that's a
different thing that you're saying it's
like you're just to me i think you're
trying to say you can relate to this
situation that yeah when you know
somebody
if i can't relate to you no no you don't
get to know you don't need to know
somebody to relate to their situation if
you see something in like you need to
know their situation you see somebody
like
if you see somebody going off but that's
not knowing them all right check this
out if you're doing whatever you're
doing right and i just it's not for me i
don't like it uh it bothers me whatever
and then one thing i find out about you
oh eric
comes from a you know a single-parent
household or got divorced or whatever
this one thing where it contextualizes
it you're like i you felt that way about
me
i get it yeah but you have to i know the
person i do
rick you're not going to convince me
you're 100 wrong about this one okay
okay uh when you're watching something
and something funny is happening you can
relate to that situation because you're
saying to yourself if i was in that
situation i would feel i would have the
same feeling or that's what the same
thing produces you don't like that's
something that adds to it what you're
saying what you're saying is like when
you that's why it goes to season two
three four five and six but like when
you look at a pilot and you don't know
anything about these people you're
laughing or enjoying because you can
relate to the situation that's why you
don't need to be mad you don't need to
know well not not always no not always
but most of those those usually don't
get picked up most of the time in
relatively speaking as great as the
pilot of frasier is and it's one of the
best the show gets better oh well
everything gets better i understand it
but what i'm saying is you don't need
to know anything about any character
then you better have unbelievable jokes
and situations but if you're not the
best writer in the world that's why it's
called you know
situational yeah comedy yes that's why
it's called that but literally the name
that's not enough fresh prince doesn't
work because
uh you know
they stole the peacock mascot and now
the the big football game's gonna go bad
at ula it works because we know these
people and we love the way they are
together i'm right i just will be right
back completely you know you
why is that funny is it funny or is it
funny because you know me and that's
rick doing it's not the snap that's
funny that's rick taking charge getting
in the way doing a schtick it's what it
is baby i know but that's
but the things you just said the things
you just said you don't need to know
that that stuff's going on you could
tell by the situation okay you can tell
by the if there's somebody annoyed with
someone else you could be like yeah i'd
be annoyed by that guy too and i would
have that same reaction you don't need
to know like people don't need to know
you to think you're annoying you're just
annoying in that situation but they do
need to know me what i mean they do need
to know they can empathize with you
know me to realize i'm more than just
annoying i know then they start to like
that person i know but you're talking
about something different all i'm saying
is initially when you're watching
something you could laugh and enjoy it
regardless of knowing them or not what
i'm saying is a show doesn't work and a
show isn't special until we really get
to know these characters
i agree with that all i'm saying is you
don't need initially that for the comedy
to work that's not why the comedy works
is what i'm saying when when when when
they were doing that documentary fake
mockumentary thing in these things
you don't necessarily need to know them
they can like you know get the
exposition out we need to know
they're the boss he's the boss yeah he's
the weird he's he's insecure he has a
modern family she doesn't model family
the pilot of that was freaking hilarious
you know it's like and you just like you
know
just like you get you get the comedy you
get the world and then after you get
then you get to know them and then
that's when it goes 10 years
but all i'm saying is initially with a
comedy even like you know when you're
doing uh stand-up comedy when you're
doing stand-up comedy and you know you
go up to you know people are like okay
come to the stage next and they're like
rick glassman they don't know nothing
about you that's why it's my job and our
job to let them know our point of view
and things about us earlier on well not
not all comics do that stephen wright
doesn't didn't do that but he's just
jokes i know but that's what i'm saying
what i'm saying is you don't need that
for people to be used to tell a story
funny tell a story if you're telling a
story i mean you can still tell a story
that people relate to people can relate
to
whatever you're saying we're arguing to
argue at this point no you are okay
if you're arguing to argue about
what what you think
makes something funny and if you think
that the initial
for a television show specifically a
comedy to work right you need to know
and care about the characters or it will
not work it takes time to get there and
it's not going to necessarily happen in
the pilot a good pilot it does and a
good pilot you find out the first like
three episodes you know you might not
know but anyway listen we're not far
apart from what we're saying i'm just
telling you i don't think i don't think
you need that's not the reason why in
the pilot of the office you thought the
look into camera and all that stuff was
funny that's not the reason yeah there
are things that are funny from strangers
i agree
that's exactly what i'm saying yeah all
right that's why i don't disagree with
what you're saying but i'm saying you
don't that's not what you need initially
you see
you're on the same page
but you like to argue okay
[Laughter]
hey
[Laughter]
now why is that funny because people
could be like yeah i've been with a
friend who like we're having an argument
he makes me feel that way they don't
need to know us to know that i would say
that because of that they do know us in
that moment they know us in that moment
because they can relate to it yes and
the more you know somebody the more you
could relate to them that's
uh that keeps it going rick we're not
saying anything different we're talking
about the timeline
the timeline rick that's a timeline
okay you say hey man i don't know when
we're ending this but let's find one
other thing all right whatever all right
i'm saying what makes a show special not
the only way to get a laugh what makes
the show special is us caring about
these people i agree that's it i agree
great but we started this by talking
about why is this funny and you said
because they know them and i'm saying no
okay that's not the initial reason why
they thought this was funny okay you
don't need you know what i'm saying
that's what i was trying to say okay you
know if you were saying like why was
season episode episode three of season
eight why was that funny
because we already know these people i
get it and what i'm saying is if no
one's ever seen the office before in
their life they could turn enough to get
them we have they can turn it on ranger
doesn't have a great relationship with
his dad or we have to know that
that willie smith uh had to move into
this fish out of water situation when in
reality carlton is the fish out of water
and we see that dynamic where he's the
odd one and we get to know this stuff
even if it's not consciously that's why
pilots suck because we have to teach the
audience so much about these people i
don't know if they i don't know if they
all suck they don't all say they don't
all suck but they're relatively even
into season one season two three you
know you could turn on something and
like i've watched the office a million
times when i do i start with the dundies
season two episode one i don't even
watch the first season anymore
what the season is great there's some
funny stuff in it but they didn't find
it until they've done this i disagree i
thought the first season was so
fantastic you know they pull in they
play basketball that's a funny there's a
lot of funny bits in it yeah that whole
the episode is freaking hilarious you
know but anyways uh
this this episode brought to you by the
office
oh my god well anyways rick uh this
episode's never coming out so is it
really not yeah i just did this to like
troll you it's not the camera's not even
on
no it is but that would be great right
you know why that's funny because i know
you oh whatever
that also what people don't know to
appreciate that joke even more
is that i have done three other of your
podcasts not three three no it's not
three i just had technical like one of
them the sound didn't work and it was
like we had this great conversation it
was during the pandemic when i was
trying to figure out how to do the zoom
[ __ ] man now i got it figured out but
now people are you're here yeah so it
sucks because i have all this great
setup now for for that i even figured
out how to get the discord in now and
like you know get it all you know what i
mean it sucks i do all my auditions like
that you know what i love about when i
do like commercials in front of you you
do them live on youtube oh i should
that'd be hilarious uh but but like
that'd be great patreon content guys i'm
about to do an audition you guys want to
be a part of it and get in trouble for
that but that would be all right right
so like uh like so so sometimes i do my
uh i sit there and i'll like because i
asked him do i need to be standing up or
whatever for this and they're like no
this is like a thing you need you know
so i just i have this setup and they
always mention it they're always like
wow what you got going on there well
it's like you know i even feel like when
i booked this pilot
i did the everything with zoom
you know so i was doing it i had to set
up i had a laugh mic on i was like you
know and i think it was just kind of
like
it's going to look better
than whoever is doing it at their like
you know with their
cameras i agree with you i i believe it
i believe stupid
does matter so but anyways rick i always
uh you know we're just always there's
always going to be i count this as like
a crossover episode i think our episode
by the way comes out um a week from
today okay well there you go you'll see
uh this one is this is sunday we
recorded this it's coming out tomorrow
monday but like all of our podcasts
between take your shoes off and rip it
with griffin it's just one big
continuous thing that we just gonna
continue to do until we're sick of doing
podcasts or the next medium comes out
and people or the kids are like pac-hey
you're still doing it's like radio
remember when people do like nobody has
radio anymore don't
was that before 95
[Laughter]
yeah i used to i used to call into radio
things all the time trying to win stuff
can't really do it i used to call into
sports talk radio shows all the time do
you did you ever record them no i should
but you didn't know how to do that at
the time once i called in is eric from
la he's gotta he wants to talk about
shaq you know to be like you know that
would be so funny to hear
i have recorded i mean i don't still
have but uh i remember i called in i got
this um
90210 boombox that some this girl that
loved 90210 got me in school when you
like exchanged gifts or not boomba just
like a little radio with a cassette
player in it and i was at my grandma's
house and i was listening to something
and it was during the holidays and angry
like angry santa it was like some one of
these radio things you want to call in
and talk to anger santa it would be you
you would be angry santa and i called in
like what do you want and i go oh
and i and i pressed record
so i don't know where that tape is
you got to find that yeah i used to lie
i remember i called into this
conservative radio and the guy was
talking about i'll never forget this man
some it was just black conservative
radio host nothing wrong with that
nothing wrong with it but it is give it
some context and it was because we get
to know him a little bit by giving us
those details yeah i agree it wasn't
it's not it doesn't matter okay so then
the guy was talking about it was
something about someone that was jewish
and i called in and i was just saying i
said i was like it doesn't matter that
the guy's jewish or whatever and then
the guy starts asking me he goes so uh
what's your background you know and then
he was trying to get me to say my
background so they then he cut me off
just to be like oh yeah that guy's like
bias okay you know you know how all
black people don't like jews
he turned it into this thing and i was
furious you know what i mean because i
was like oh you piece of [ __ ] like and
then it was just like he was just one of
these race it was race-baiting like he
was doing it on purpose to try and i was
like oh man and that's what they just
you did a lot on uh conservative radio a
great segment to do if not its own show
would be just our homework like our prep
is calling up all these different radio
shows and just playing characters or
being on whatever just play them and
then we come on here and we do like uh
so i got one for you i called it this
conservative radio thing and we you know
what i mean and you need to animate it
and stuff oh man it was just yeah i used
to i used to love that it's like this
people just don't do that anymore
they're not doing it i feel like we
should do it more for like pockets i
want to do it live i would like to do
one of these one time live with you live
on youtube will we be seeing the screen
yeah yeah i turn when i do it live my
guy's here i turn this around and then
he's like doing like the hey look this
up and it's all right here on the screen
i did one once uh uh with adam ray in my
apartment like it was this like we sell
tickets for it oh yeah that's different
and uh it was cool but there was a
little bit of a lag and i didn't i
remembered after you told me yeah when
you use obs you have to like change the
thing yeah you got to get it you got to
give it a delay and i'm like i'm sorry
everybody who bought it
yeah it's it's a lot of like it's really
a lot to like when you do this stuff
they don't tell you all these little
things they'll teach they'll teach you
about genghis khan in high school but
they don't teach you how to live stream
on youtube and i think that's a problem
you make you're being facetious but
i think that is the future
i took typing in high school so
i was just talking about this with my
buddy david you know i'm talking about
yes i took typing in high school and i
was on my way
oh yeah my senior year was the last year
they went to computers the next year so
what i'm saying is you tell me this i
think i feel like sullivan just told me
this oh really yeah like he was like the
last person where they would do it where
it was a keyboard you bought this on
your podcast
i don't think so there was a screen
there was a screen it wasn't a computer
but there was a digital little screen oh
no it didn't heat it yet that wasn't me
but i was just talking about this myself
too just being like you know talk oh i
was talking about this on gentogen my
other new podcast dude check it out
youtube.comgens
genderjen jen i don't even know what
they're anyway you know
so it's like
you know we just do uh um
anyway now they're teaching typing or
keyboarding or whatever they call it now
it's like second third grade so i think
eventually how to use technology and
work in technology is gonna join it's
gonna go into the curriculum of like you
know
schools and stuff or maybe you can make
that like you know i wanna be an
emphasis on this or maybe i wish in high
school you didn't have to have this core
curriculum that like you could you could
go back and maybe your junior senior
year you could be like hey i'm thinking
about going into this and then they had
other classes for you to take
hey
that's not a bad idea and really we
could talk about it all we want and
nothing will happen until you call your
congress people put the number up at the
bottom call your congress people and let
them know i want my kid to know how to
do his taxes i want my kids to
understand how to how to handle life
when you're pregnant i want my kids to
understand how to maintain a
relationship and what loyalty is i
wanted to know how do i change a tire
okay how do i live stream on youtube
call your congresswoman
or man
right and let them know that
you know what we want to fix
yeah my name is rick glassman check out
eric griffin on the take your shoes off
podcast next week or if it's our you
know
maybe it's already out if you're
listening to this a little late
and uh also go to rick glassman.com and
check out my store a lot of merchandise
i have these hats
where they say
and we're back
i love that do you i could get you one
yeah that's great you gotta get ones
with a snap on it i got music somebody
said it should be the outro music
playing right now oh somebody said i
should it was a good call but i don't
know where to find him i should get
snapback hats
i love it so the music's going let me
help you out here no there's no
this is just the outro music ladies and
gentlemen thank you for watching uh
riffer with griffin
um i'm uh
on twitch daily twitch air griffin
gaming
um so all rick's information will be on
the bottom there
and uh you know it's always great to
have rick on the podcast i appreciate
you being here you know we love there's
love there's arguing there's fun
because you got to know each other you
found it out when you drove when to put
the power so kind and so calm the lord
thanks for watching drink it
and drink it up i'm rick glassman cheers
fade to black but we can still see us a
little still fading to black
rickclassman.com
now it still shows like other episodes
that you know check out this episode
click here to see this episode
that's a wrap cut it
brilliant
you